this is the production of Cornell
University
so thank you for the opportunity today I
would like to show some results that you
have got in Brazil for vodka corn and
some light are you sure that our
tropical cards not so top coat but you
have work in this specious f throat coat
and also i would like to present some
issues that you have to brazil in some
perspectives for the coming future so
take adventure that you are paying
attention to me i don't know what will
happen in your future i would like to
introduce my my team partners and
support nowadays i have 10 PhD students
working in my lab I don't have masters
or I just want undergrad student that
you call a dick in a sad initiating in
scientists or scientific schooler for
under red house I also have two
technicians work with me in the main the
main reason that we organize our group
and you have work of the menu goal of
work group is throw hard for the second
growing season in Brazil have two
growing seasons in the summer is the
first and we call the winter or the
second growing CEO of course but you
don't have a winter if you compare like
a if a co-ed we can have a fall or at
least express so this second droid
season have increased in the last years
mainly in the last three years and the
demand of four new hybrids for new
varieties for the second relatives also
has increased so we have some
international partners to develop or her
job so John Luke is one of work but best
partners and choreographers you are here
when you are not I changed with the best
one
it seemed to haul a grata it's another
guy that have a lot of from our project
I will take no University Jenny new
Michigan State University Gustavo scopus
and animal in Wisconsin so besides crack
or I also have some projects with
another company's some private and
others in order the government companies
for example I have some projects within
grappa in rocky area I grab a forage
graph that closer Nine video actors in
the zoo it's baby this is the most
important crop in Brazil the mainly for
this cattle so beans in coconut all
these projects relative apply genome
selection try to improve this game in
accelerate this kid the way to select
brand I also have one projects EFE at
continuous Institute arrogant and coffee
coffea arabica it's a self crop i also
have projects with to private companies
one for protocol corn and other signing
to support all these students and
researchers most of my fellowships and
scholarships are provided by caps and CN
picky these are federal conscious that
offer disclosure for students i also
have funny from Cepeda it's I stairwell
foundation only for the San Paulo state
and DuPont pioneer two years ago I got a
lower called young professor our based
on my research in genome selection
portrait cohort so things they they have
support my lab in genotype in some
resources and exchange some of these is
a nice so a short overview browse about
Brazilian court so the Brazilian card
had can be separated into different age
until eight and after age after age we
had a great migration in the car these
immigration was due to new areas the
government and the price of the land
stimulate farmers from the standard part
of presumed agree to the central air and
in these areas the mainly crop was
fighting but the farmers need to improve
the DOA to take advantage of the weather
because in that regions you can do more
than one growing season three years and
also find a way to pay the machine not
only using on fire but if you have
weather conditions soil conditions you
can have two or three growing seasons
and divide the cost of the machines for
two or three so this migration into a
tea mainly ninety percent of corn
president Clark will produce here then
we start this migration to this central
areas that you call say hub it's similar
to suffer enough African savanna it's
the same type of soil the same time of
weather so 20 years ago at approximately
20 years ago these second growing season
started in for small farmers in this
region here and we came increasing year
by year until five years ago when you
had a switch the second growing season
we call suffering that in Portuguese if
you translate to English it means a
small growing season for small crop so
this is small became the bigger so five
years ago we have this switch and
nowadays the most import the robeks
isn't for card is the winter growth it's
the suffering it can we call suffering
so in this painting at the idea DS we
expect this difference we're increasing
the coming years of course you will
achieve a certain plateau the summer
going to do not disappear but you'll
reduce in some areas only for this outer
part of Brazil and now that you can see
in the central areas things like this we
have this combines harvesting corn and
harvesting siding and at the same time
you have some planters showing record
it's common to see in the central areas
of Brazil when you harvest the card you
can plant cotton or beans and so on so
we have these procedures in me in almost
all farmers big farms in this central
area the problem is when you change the
growing season we change to completely
change the environment did they in life
and also the rainfall and the
temperature so normally we plant the
second growing season in january or
early februari and we will harvest is
this corn in end of May or in the origin
we need that this core developer well
during this first period here on to the
soil to the flowering time where you
have a great amount of rainfall in the
temperature extremes to be stable across
the year the temperature is not a
problem in this area will have a lot of
warm normal it this is the average
normal during the day we have 10 4
Fahrenheit and the front is not during
the day promise at nine at night the
temperature keeps very high and more
than 8482 if you consider the ottoman
temperature for corn that's near to this
temperature
that's okay if you see during the day
this inverter however is you have these
at night we have a lot of respiration or
reading but there is no photosynthesis
so become sumption for energy keep in a
high level and maybe this is your reason
that the Brazilian corn in the central
areas don't have doesn't have a great
heel or high heels leveling in this
central area and leave for the coming
years this is one of the main
interesting things to solve part to fix
in Brazilian quartz change this angle of
this part pattern here of the
respiration curve trying that isn't even
though the plant is under high
temperatures the respiration rate tends
to decrease faster than normal you have
seen in the tropical car so we have
other issues because we be great the
area you change the style change the
weather change the period of the year so
we have other issues one of these is
price system it now we have this product
because we completely fighting for areas
we compete with other crops so it's miss
could forecast what what will be the
amount of quantity you have in the
coming growing season so sometimes
farmers plant a lot sometimes there is
no cornella so due to this price
instability some farmers try to predict
how much nitrogen they will be spent in
this growing season so normally they put
low levels of nitrogen so when you
develop a new variety or new hybrids for
these central areas these new barytes
must be nitrogen use efficiency also we
have a pattern of rainfall
but something else something weird
always happen this rain fall season can
be shorter or longer or just change the
period so we also need varieties wider
use efficient and at the same time
earlier onion is a sport so normally we
have hybrids in that in that region that
from plan to flowering time it takes 55
day 52 days but the idea is to reduce
this this period but don't change it all
change the you so another thing is
tolerance for high temperatures mainly
at night another thing is 0 to 20 years
ago we have our major part or major
production in this sound recorder focus
analysis in the central area we are not
sure if we import you journalists will
select these new varieties or these new
areas or just move this very variety for
this new area so one question 20 years
ago we had a temperate or subtropical
channel class nowadays you are working
in central areas like tropical areas we
have we have worked with correction of
life or just companies move the general
path will try to select something good
that and another problem that you have
is Brazilian law for consumer protection
allows that anyone anywhere can take the
nuva right in using our building program
without the linear oil without any
agreement not anything if I release a
good for general can take at the same
moment is my new car and used the cross
in his program and it's necessarily I
don't say thank you no problem so based
on that many companies left those
generally those skins to improve general
files for a long term ago and the idea
is only recycling these materials take
matures for from the other companies
staff dihybrid select lines cross your
testers and see what happens like a
loader regain in this rotary game the
loser is the farmer goes into the last
20 years the things that you have seen
is a plateau of productivity mainly
because if you self a hybrid this hybrid
normally resulting by a cross between
two heterotic groups when your self
needs we have like a real a recombinant
blue line that is like a mosaic between
these hetero it's difficult to achieve
the same level of heterogeneous again
and finally is it possible to use genome
selection to solve the six we have a
fast integration but we think the
original path didn't change so fast so
we need a tool to do this change and try
to follow the same speed that the
integration all the problems have
happened to address these three things I
brought three taters that we tweet
during the last two years trying to
figure out what what happened in our
general puzzler what's happening the
hidden gem okay so the first things
what's your general plan we publish a
newspaper last year in plus one and try
to an end in order to understand what's
your German path you take we took 20
hybrids 20 hybrids that was considered
the most important hybrid simple zealand
field covering seven reading company
from public to private companies and
this hybrid represent ninety percent of
the brazilian general class can be in
seed sales or in the area covered by
this hybrid
we genotyped these hybrids using the
alumina Golden Gate a low density low
density panel but I think it's necessary
to coverage not in see the relationship
between these general plus coupon by
useful parts to disease genotyping and
we also include the name parents in them
that was developed here to see what's
the relationship between our hybrids and
between our brazilian hybrids and the
parents that was used to form the net so
the first result show we have seven
companies I'd Romain and I remained it's
up it's been central in Brazil they
don't use among samples they collect on
other names they have two brains trying
to avoid some products as we know that
nonsense is not more friendly company so
we see that Dow is the company there in
average is more related with other
companies in average you don't have a
strong relationship between the
companies Jeremy plot device down so
when you put these hybrids and try to
figure out this structure we see these
[ __ ] it's almost the same here we
have these two any hybrids that will
level with and the company's the general
part of the company's things to be
separate so it's a it's good differ that
we thought when they try to sell hybrids
from the other companies and use it like
in there their general pot now nowadays
these jumpers not so early so as we
expect it it's do it for heaven also now
we have a good amount of genetic
variability but my concern is for the
coming years
if this behavior remain what you have
any communist my but the problem that we
didn't fight is when you put these
hybrids with Dean and Perry here are
deposited here in Brazil there are
hybrids are when you put in the
population structure you can see our
Brazilian harvested we thought that they
are tropical they are in the same is
rooted in scintillating for corn and
here you can see the truth Colin's that
we were used to from dinner so as I
expect the companies didn't bring new
germ oppa they only move the jungle
paths for the central areas and try to
select something new so our general buzz
is not so tropical else's office Soto
dresses second one at the first problem
to select for you and flowering time
rain monster as you call earliness to
try to select those things together we
did a very simple in classical paper we
saw this it was done for by my math
three students two years ago and to
address this problem he uses 64 in grid
lines that we call that time protocol
line we evaluate this local line for a
grand meal day to flowering in grain
moisture granule of course production in
days to flowering in Grain monster is in
this case is that are they are
indicators for precocity organists so we
need what one line or one hybrid death
is spent a little time to firing and
when I will hire harvest this hybrid the
Glen watch which tends to be very low so
we've already slide during two years two
locations in two levels of nitrogen
available
based on the phenotypes we proceed with
two ways to analyze this data set the
blood single trait in the blood move to
trade in the blood single trade I
evaluate each one of these traits
separately then I put all these traits
together and use a mood trade then after
i get i got these blood we use three
ways three ways to do the simultaneous
election the additive effect giving the
same weight for each one of the straight
calamba mock that stick your rank
selection linux independent schooling
level they value what is the best
scenario compare based on the games in
constraints of selection for all these
traits if i select just one survived
when you evaluate the correlations of
this race yes you can see that only days
to flowering in grandma's moisture are
related so it was not expect in your
journal path but the correlation is not
so strong and when you evaluate and
compare the way to predict breathing
valves or the genotypic value for our
hive or ryan or hybrid you can see the
good single trait or multi-plate for
these traits are not so different
because this trade the coverings between
the streets not so high so there is no
correction for between the strength in
the ranks or degenerative catalyst for
the line on other hand if i select based
on index election rank or curling levels
i can have complete different results or
hung ranks in the best that we we then
phi is the additive model it's a good
new because it's mosquito this is the
simplest way I just need to figure out
what we wait for each one of the traits
and when I plot these you switch breaks
here you didn't fight I need one line
that needs few days to flowering that at
the harvest time there is a little
amount of water in the grain and also
high levels of you using these index
which is edited in fact index in boot
loop single trait I could select the
best lines for this purpose so this
mutiny selections for grain you or
anything is possible and the good news
using this simple way it's the most
efficient way to do that so we have it
nowadays a lot of markers we have a lot
of these same things but you can solve
some problems using classical bleeding
to finally genome selection for nitrogen
use efficient this paper was not
published yet we sent to cross ice my
teg students and with the aid of Rosa we
evaluate 739 hybrids this harvest were
obtained from our ice crossing between
49 grid lines these hybrids were in two
locations to nitrogen levels for grain
yield plant height and we general fight
the parents using the f metrics a cheat
after credit control we had almost 54 k
is nice and the idea is to select one hi
Bertha under low nitrogen condition this
hyper has a good performance but if in
that year the farmers decide oh I you
put more nitrogen so I need one hybrid
at the same time is tolerance
but also responsive or nitrogen I we
need hybrids that these two phases so
because of this we evaluate into levels
of nitrogen and try to figure out the
best way to proceed genomes collection
under debate in this case G bodies
locations linked levels of nitrogen so
this scenarios we compared three models
the first model is the simplest one
direction norm across environmentalist
where we have just the environment
affects at six effects and you may
affect fortune effects the second one is
reaction R plus gye effects or on the
website the third is like a rigid
regression use this six the first two
models are giblet the third one is gie
model where instead of using developed
we use e RR in this model we have an
environment affect six effects the main
marker fact instead of name aside for
genotype and you have a deviation or the
effect of the g by marker effect we also
test two Colonels the linear the most
common proposed by the memory of our
rating in 2008 and the Gaussian kernel
proposed left almost two years ago the
garfish on colonel the only thing
different is this when you will do the
kinship matrix we use the explanation
between the distance between each one of
these individuals and you'll divide by
the million here after some procedures
we use this bandwidth as equal one
trying to avoid some problems like
sparse kinship matters
when you use this second one the
Gaussian kernel it's similar to air air
HTS method where that you can capture
some no additive effects so our idea
that using this social can you can have
different components of range for each
environment in capture geez not linear
effects or no additive effect the due to
the device because validation with
dupatta way we use eighty percent of the
hybrid to training set at the indy
remaining twenty percent for aesthetic
we use the second way proposed Bible
game that mimics a problem for each for
the Breeders we have some line
separating some environments but not in
all environments and we use a BG our
package it's a vision package for genome
selection to run all these and energy in
the result the result that we got was
really good for grain you using or plant
height using that model the region
regression model when I have the main
effect for markers in the deviation
effect from action due to the device for
both trades we have a great increasing
accuracy almost eighty percent in plant
height in seventy percent for gratitude
so I can predict regardless using high
nitrogen low nitrogen or the location we
can predict very well using dissolve so
this model using gas okay the ocean
Colonel seems to be better and I'll in
much better than model we can predict
parallel hybrids for this condition in
if low nitrogen or highlight version we
also have worked on improved protocol
inducers of hot lights when you bring
these integers from
see me to our temperate areas and put in
brazilian conditions normally the
weather's 2 are so we cannot obtain any
headlights so one way is trying to cross
the road coke heart and try to select
something more adapted for this high
levels and culture we also deserve some
are packets I i present these two
packets here you see variety and be
brutally we provide the package to work
with this bigger data set for molecular
markers and be breeder it's a interface
with of are using trying to teach and
learn plant building content my lab the
main reasons in the main object is
twenty-twenty vision x engine understood
and always we try to use our channel
pass evaluating for nitrogen utilization
and related rates like routes through
trades or physiological traits of so on
since 2004 14 we also will make
agreement with a private company and try
to apply this hydro to phenotype in your
general files and trying to adopt
something cheap easy and fast to collect
this data and apply the vent readings
but the main reason for all these things
slip already is integrating develop a
new brainy schemes there is no reason to
study some from branch separated if you
do not have one way what you don't think
how can integrate and reshape my
breeding program and transfer my
building from something more efficient
and something faster than before so I
present a lot of problems about you but
you have many things to do and you can
see this in the
coming to in two ways a prom can see can
be seen as a opportunity to I know that
Brazil about Brazil has a lot of
misconceptions I know that Brazil we
seen abroad is bananas monkey forest
anaconda and so we can hear good things
about Brazil we are cannibal [ __ ] yet
we are all these things it's part of
nature nature it's part of our culture
the misconception is we are not just
music as you have won some of the best
universities in agricultural college in
the tropical belt so we have all seen
grappa in brier yet regarding big
companies that have have deserved great
researches in many areas in energy so
this the misconception is just
summarized resuming this thing that is
broadcast first to the rest of the world
on the other hand we have real problems
the real problem is you is corruption
and we don't know exactly how much money
we threw away every year due to the
corruption that are deployed besides
political four ish we have our
ingredients to be 60 thinking about
agriculture because tropical areas are
challenging we have a great for a bit of
environment inside these are the brazil
match for the weather so we have six
seven different types of weather in just
one country and these uses are Brazilian
fireman if you make a blend of these
things emerge the amount of environment
that that you have in our hands to
select in captured use interaction also
for many parties in the
light yellow your area we can have a
degree through up to three grown kids so
if different weather across the year
with different rainfall different day
length so we have a lot of interactions
i also have a great diverse of
everything with for me it's a great
source of a hot water the great source
of hypothesis to test and try to figure
out the problem but maybe the better the
best advantage that you have nowadays we
have nine million hectares that is to us
up table I mean I'm not talking about
the Amazon forest I'm talking about this
area here we have a great amount of land
that you can use it for the coming years
so maybe there is no other another
country with the same amount of area
available to expand agriculture to
expand the research and all other things
the problem in this area is
transportation we can produce pure oil
in tropical areas we learn the things we
know how can I do how we can do these
things but the problem is I have to
reproduce after the production how
collective production and try this call
the production to the court and export
all the six probably this is the main
issue for the community the main issue
will not be genetics will be logistics
but as your former president you did say
yes we can probably in the coming years
we have the solution for thank
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu